[Music]
we all know was like everything from
money status monies power money sex
appeal yeah I just I just read that the
the more beautiful the woman the bigger
the diamond and the uglier the man who
gave it to her you know so it's all of
its its why is that you know that has
nothing to do with the daily
transactions that is something emotional
that's how the man believes he's gonna
feel with a beautiful wife how the woman
feels when she's got a you know
expensive rock on her hand these are all
feelings there's status like I made it
you know proving yourself to your third
grade teacher or your your nemesis in
high school or your parents you know
there's so many ways in which we project
onto money the ability to not only make
us happy but to make us better or better
than other people or or safe or you know
so many deep gut level emotional
feelings are playing themselves out in
our relationship with money and you know
fine I'm not saying it shouldn't happen
like we would learn to be very conscious
and we're gonna have any emotions in our
relationship with money you know I'm not
saying that I'm just saying the more
aware you are of what you're projecting
onto money in terms of of meeting
emotional and psychological and even
spiritual needs the clearer you're gonna
be in those daily transactions in fact
that's part of why once you start to
become conscious the flow of money and
stuff in your life this way you stop
spending so much money but around that
is is the cultural narrative the the the
rules of the game of our economy the
financial system in so many ways governs
not just our daily lives but who wins
and who loses who has power who does not
have power who gets to set you know say
what the game is who gets to play by the
rules and break the rules I mean this is
a cultural context that has nothing to
do particularly with what's going on in
our individual traumas and history
it has to do with a longer historical
moment in time and the basic meme of the
financial system is growth it mean it's
really in a way it's sort of a very long
con Ponzi scheme because it has to keep
growing in order to keep meeting its
obligations
you know money is produced I mean the
actual piece of paper and metal the
credit that you have does isn't just
like you go to a job and somebody gives
you some pieces of paper it's money is
loaned into being by banks you know
banks have the authorization to create
money but they it's not as not like they
have to have you know a thousand dollars
in the vault in order to lend you a
thousand dollars no they have to have a
hundred dollars in the vault to lend you
a thousand dollars and then they lend
you the thousand dollars with interest
so everything in the in the world of
money everything has to grow everything
has to keep growing or the it's game
over which is a difficulty for us now
because because of the capacity of the
planet to support this ideology so
that's that that construct of money
which is fascinating people study
economics and and and the financial
system we're mesmerized by how people
have played this system to the detriment
of many people except for themselves and
then but what we say is that outside of
that whole thing those are all stories
what we actually know for sure as
individual human beings we know that we
have a body that you know we know that
we're alive and that we invest some of
the minutes of our lives some of the
vital force of our lives in a process
that produces money for us however it
produces it like whatever it is we
invest some of our precious life energy
in the this thing called getting money
so money for us is your life energy the
value of money to you is how much of you
you invested in
getting it and once you understand that
once you understand that money is
something that's abstract and seems
unlimited like if I go into debt it
doesn't matter I'll just keep having
jobs and I'll keep paying it off I mean
it's just endless sort of stumbling
process but you understand that your
life is limited you know we've got I'm
gonna say eighty-five years in the
planet because now I'm 73 so I don't say
75 anymore yeah so we've got a certain
limited time in the planet we're gonna
spend a third of it sleeping you know
we're gonna spend another third of it
you know commuting showering and you
know and and and sitting at a desk and
doing somebody else's bidding yeah
that's not a lot of life so you think I
got a third I have a third of my waking
hours or mine to do whatever I want
you know Who am I so it's like it then
sends it into an existential question
Who am I what do I care about what do I
want the impact of my actions to be what
do I want to learn what do I want to
understand what I want to feel taste
touch you know what do I want in what
Mary Oliver calls my one wild and
precious life so that once you do that
tip and then you go like okay so what am
i earning I'm earning let's say thirty
six dollars an hour and I'm not gonna do
the whole shaggy-dog story of like you
know you've got to add on to that hour
the extra time you spend getting
training and commuting and you know the
vacation where you know the first three
days your vacation where you are inert
you're just staring you know those are
all those that's all time associated
with that hour the commute expense of
the training and and you know the your
consultant and you think you make a lot
of money but you spend hours and hours
to get the business for that one hour of
paid employment on average I will say
just run the experiment in your own life
that $36 for an hour will whittle down
to about a quarter of that
so call that $9 so now we have a figure
an hour of my life is worth $9 that's
interesting okay
going out for coffee and muffin that's
an hour yeah so so then you have to ask
value questions around that about like
am I really glad that I spent an hour of
my one wild and precious life on this
coffee and muffin how do I actually even
engage with that question the way we
suggest you engage with it is this did
it make me happy commensurate with the
value that I convey I put on this one
hour of my life you know yeah you know
like without that coffee and muffin
every day my life would be like you know
sort of at a 50 rather than a 90 is it
an align with my values with what I say
is important and without what I think my
purpose in life is and these are not
easy questions to ask but it's you might
as well ask it when you're buying your
coffee and muffin when else you're gonna
ask it you know what to what am i
dedicating this my existence and and
somehow or another you sort of get a
vague sense purchased by purchase it's
really the most amazing meditation on
how do I invest my life to create the
maximal value for myself other people in
the world
[Music]